the signal fire is no doubt one of the
oldest technologies for transmitting
information perhaps dating back to the
first controlled use of fire it allows
one person to influence another's belief
state across a distance because with the
ability to notice either the presence or
absence of something we are able to
switch between one of two belief states
one difference two states and if we look
back in history we find that this was of
great importance to military powers
which all rely on effective
communications and a great place to
begin is with the Greek myth of Cadmus
a Phoenician prince who introduced the
phonetic letters to Greece the Greek
alphabet bore wrote from the Phoenician
letters along with light and cheap
papyrus affected the transfer of power
from the priestly to the military class
and Greek military history provides
clear evidence of the first advancements
and communications stemming from the use
of signal torches Polybius was a Greek
historian born in 200 BC he wrote the
histories which is a treasure trove of
detail related to the communication
technologies of the time he writes the
power of acting at the right time
contributes very much to the success of
enterprises and fire signals are the
most efficient of all devices which aid
us to do this however the limitation of
a signal fire was clear to him he writes
it was possible for those who had agreed
on this to convey information that say a
fleet had arrived but when it came to
some citizens having been guilty of
treachery or a massacre having taken
place in town things that often happen
but cannot all be foreseen all such
matters defied communication by fire
signal a fire signal is great when the
space of possible messages is small such
as enemy has arrived or
arrived however when the message space
which is the total number of possible
messages grows there was a need to
communicate many differences and in the
histories Polybius describes a
technology developed by NES Tacitus one
of the earliest Greek writers on the art
of war from the fourth century BC and
his technology was described as follows
those who are about to communicate
urgent news to each other by fire signal
should procure two vessels of exactly
the same width and depth and through the
middle should pass a rod graduated in
two equal sections each clearly marked
off from the next denoted with a Greek
letter each letter would correspond to a
single message in a lookup table which
contained the most common events that
occur in war to communicate they would
proceed as follows first the sender
would raise his torch to signal he had a
message the receiver would then raise
his torch signaling he was ready to
receive it then the sender would lower
his torch and they would both begin to
drain their vessels from a bored hole of
equal size at the bottom now when the
event is reached the sender raises his
torch to signal that they should both
stop the flow of water
this results in equal water levels
denoting a single shared message
this ingenious method used differences
in time to signal messages however it's
expressive capability was limited mainly
due to its speed Polybius dendrites of a
newer method originally devised by
Democritus which he claims was perfected
by myself and quite definite and capable
of dispatching with accuracy every kind
of urgent message his method now known
as the polybius square works as follows
two people separated by a distance each
have ten torches separated into two
groups of five to begin the sender
raises a torch and waits for the
receiver to respond then the sender
lights a certain number from each group
of torches and raises them the receiver
then counts the number of torches lit in
the first group this number defines the
role position in an alphabetic grid they
share and the second group of torches
signifies the column position in this
grid the intersection of the row and
column number defines the letter sent
realize this method can be thought of as
the exchange of two symbols each group
of five torches is a symbol which was
limited to five differences from one to
five torches together these two symbols
multiply to give five times five equals
twenty-five differences not five plus
five this multiplication demonstrates an
important combinatorial understanding in
our story it was explained clearly in a
six century BC Indian medical text
attributed to Sushruta an ancient Indian
sage as follows given six different
spices how many possible different
tastes can you make well the process of
making a mixture can be broken down into
six questions do you add a yes or no do
you add b c d e and f realize this
multiplies into a tree of possible
answer sequences two times two times two
times two times two times two equals 64
64 different sequences of answers are
therefore possible realize that given n
yes-or-no questions there are two to the
power of n possible answer sequences now
in 1605 Francis Bacon clearly explained
how this idea could allow one to send
all letters of the alphabet using only a
single difference with his bilateral
cipher bacon wrote famously the
transposition of two letters by five
placings will be sufficient for
thirty-two differences for by this art a
way is opened whereby a man may Express
and signify the intentions of his mind
at any distance of place with objects
which are capable of a two-fold
difference only this simple idea of
using a single difference to communicate
the alphabet really took flight in the
17th century due to the invention of the
telescope by lippershey in 1608 and
Galileo in 1609
because quickly the magnification power
of the human eye jumped from three to
eight to thirty three times and beyond
so the observation of a single
difference could be made at a much
greater distance
Robert Hooke an English polymath
interested in improving the capability
of human vision using lenses ignited
progress when he told the Royal Society
in 1684 that suddenly quote with a
little practice the same character may
be seen at Paris within a minute after
it hath been exposed at London this was
followed by a flood of inventions to
pass differences more effectively across
greater distances one technology from
1795 perfectly demonstrates the use of a
single difference to communicate all
things Lord George Murray's shutter
Telegraph was Britain's reaction to the
Bonapartist threat to England it was
composed of six rotating shutters which
could be oriented as either open or
closed here each shutter can be thought
of as a single difference with six
shutters we have six questions open or
closed providing us with two to the
power of six or 64 differences enough
for all letters digits and more now
realize that each observation of the
shutter Telegraph can also be thought of
as the observation of one of 64
different paths through a decision tree
and with a telescope it was now possible
to send letters at an incredible
distance between beacons however an
observation in 1820 led to a
revolutionary technology which forever
changed how far these differences could
travel between signalling beacons this
assured in new ideas which launched us
into the Information Age